twitter permanently suspending president  trump's account citing risks of further  incitement of violence  trump had previously had his account  suspended and then it was reinstated  upon which he announced he would not  attend president-elect joe biden's  inauguration  but the permanent suspension happened  within the past hour other social media  outlets like facebook have also taken  action against the president  banning president trump from posting  indefinitely or at least until the  inauguration  actions being taken by the social media  platforms is appropriate  but the cause is the person who's in the  white house  and he shouldn't be in the white house  experts say social media companies are  legally allowed to restrict user  accounts including the presidents